hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
this is a hundredth episode of
this
series
uh i started doing this right after the
pandemic hit and there was a lockdown
and kids couldn't go to school and
things like that
and i thought
well let me provide a bit of a public
service and uh
try and do some sort of backup science
teaching so to speak
um
and uh try and answer questions about
science and technology for kids and
others
people seem to like this and i found it
really interesting and i think i've
gotten to be a better explainer as a
result of doing this so i've kept doing
it
and i hope people are having fun with it
and
i'd love to get feedback and input from
people
you can find also the uh
the recorded episodes of this are
available in a variety of formats don't
ask me exactly what
um as
and there's also a nice website
that includes the
word clouds
from the transcripts of all of these
episodes
and you can pretty easily find from
those word clouds what kinds of topics
were discussed each time i'm sort of
trying to make an attempt to not sort of
rediscuss the same things multiple times
um
because i think we're building up kind
of an interesting library
of uh
uh of podcasts basically about um well
answering questions about science and
technology
all right well
with that said let me um
jump into some of the questions from
today
all right we have a
a question
um
[Music]
from
zaydon
how is computation in nature differ
different from computation that a
computer does
well gosh that's something i've spent
a decent part of my life thinking about
kind of what computation is
and its
kind of instantiation in different
places
so well what is computation
computation is about
following definite rules it's about how
you
have
a structured
thing
that
is
through time follows definite rules i
think that's sort of the core of the
concept of computation
is that you have something defined in
some structured way
and
over the course of time
it is
uh
changing according to certain definite
rules
and
the thing in in fact what we've realized
from our understanding now in the last
couple of years of sort of the really
computational foundations of physics
that time itself
is really
in the physical world
this process of the computation of the
next state of the universe from the
previous one so there's a there's a deep
connection between sort of the progress
of time and a computation taking place
but when we think about
computation
as this kind of following of rules with
a definite structure
uh
the
the question is where does that play out
well it plays out
in a completely abstract way i mean we
could just
uh
abstractly write down on a piece of
paper something where we're taking some
particular uh set up it might be a a
line of black and white cells and we're
applying rules at every step that say if
the black and white cells have this
configuration changing them in this way
and so on we could do that
on a piece of paper with a with a with a
you know with an ink pen we could do
that uh
in a piece of electronics we can do that
in lots of different places it's an
abstract kind of thing
that is just this abstract process of
computation it's just like we can say
you know two plus two equals four
we can say there's an abstract thing we
can also say you know two apples plus
two apples is four apples and we have
the physical apples there to count them
out
but there's something there's an
abstract version of mathematics that is
abstracted from the particular appleness
of the apples so to speak it's just
about
abstract numbers and similarly with
computation that's kind of an abstract
way of thinking about computation that
doesn't have any particulars of what the
thing that we're describing is we're
just talking about it as something
abstract
so okay so what does that mean in terms
of how we implement computation well
we have a
the
sort of a core way of implementing
computation which is using digital
electronics
where the things we're dealing with are
collections of electrons that represent
let's say binary bits that build up to
all of the data that we store in a
computer we might have billions of these
binary bits that make images or make
text or make sounds or whatever else and
when i say make they are the raw
material which we then can interpret
as
images or sounds or whatever and we have
particular devices whether they're
displays or loudspeakers or whatever
that take those raw abstract bits
and convert them into something like you
know pressure waves in the air for sound
or uh
configurations of light for displays and
so on
so
the the best the sort of instance that
we have developed most in technology is
having this abstract idea of computation
sort of realized in terms of collections
of electrons in semiconductors
in microprocessors
with sort of uh powered by electricity
that's the instance of computation that
we are most most familiar with
but in fact this idea of following rules
and systems that sort of progress
through time by following rules that's
something that is happening all over the
place it's the core thing that's
happening in nature it's the core thing
that's happening in the physical world
it's there are many different possible
ways in which you can in principle
implement that
you can you can see that kind of
application rules play out
so people have experimented over the
years with different kinds of ways to do
computation for example you could do it
instead of using electrons you could do
it using photons using light you could
do it using fluidics you could do it
using little uh
fluid and tubes and so on you could do
it
using all sorts of different um um
uh
different kind of physical media you
could do it using some mechanical device
where the question of whether there's a
bit there depends on whether some lever
is up or down
there's a lot of different kind of
physical
realizations of the same kind of
computational idea
now another place where one can do it is
with molecules where the the kind of the
the
the kind of bits the data are encoded in
whether certain molecules are are
attached to each other or not or how the
molecules are arranged and so on and
biology
and us are
really the only great example that
exists so far of molecular scale
computing of computing where this
abstract idea of following these rules
is played out in terms of molecules and
that's sort of what a lot of the core of
what biology is
now if we say okay so these computations
that are happening
one feature of computations that we
typically do on computers is
we set them up we define
how the
the the computation should be set up to
run
i should say that that um one of the
sort of core ideas about computation is
the notion of universal computation the
notion that
when you have a system that's set up
with particular kinds of rules
you can have it so that by just changing
how you initially set the system up
you can make that system emulate
the behavior of any other system
so that's kind of the essence of how
computers universal computers work you
can have a computer that has you know
it's it's made from one microprocessor
manufacturer or another microprocessor
manufacturer it has different intrinsic
instructions in the microprocessor but
by the time you build up the level layer
of software the actual functionality
that that software can can execute is
the same it's just compiled differently
onto those different microprocessors and
a more extreme version of that is if you
were implementing something on a fluidic
computer for example you would take all
those things that you want to you know
add numbers or something like this that
would all eventually get converted down
to these little pressure waves and
fluids and an opening and closing of
valves in the fluidic system it will be
implemented very differently from the
way it's implemented on a digital
electronic computer but nevertheless
sort of the abstract description would
be the same and in addition if it's a
universal fluidic computer the actual
operation of the the computer uh can be
can have a particular form but by just
changing how you set up the initial
state of the system you can have it
emulate the behavior of any other system
so you could have it emulate the
behavior of your some particular digital
electronic computer or some other
fluidic computer or whatever else
but one feature of of the computations
that we do
on our typical computers is we write
programs where we kind of imagine that
we know what the point of the program is
and how it's going to behave
when we look at systems in nature that
we can identify as doing computations we
are typically not the ones setting up
those computations to be done the
computation is just happening uh through
the actual sort of process of of
evolution through time of the system in
nature so
we have sort of control over the
computations that we're doing in digital
electronic computers that's why and how
we set them up sort of the intermediate
case is molecular biology where there's
a certain kind of understandable
narrative and intentionality to what's
happening in biological systems but
we're not as directly able to sort of
specify the program as we do when we use
digital electronic computers so i think
the the difference is that there's sort
of this notion of computation in the
wild
and there's the versus computation that
has been domesticated where we're
specifying what should happen what
program should be being run and so on um
the uh um
um
the the thing that um
um
uh
let's see so where was i
uh
the um
uh
the question of of um
what um
uh
of sort of
computation under our control versus
computation happening in the wild
and
we can imagine
um
many
uh
one one of the things that's sort of
interesting and it's it's kind of a core
idea
in the sort of area of quantum computing
is
what other kinds of physical systems can
we take to use as computers different
from semiconductors and electronics and
so in quantum computing their ideas
about photons their ideas about
superconducting devices ion traps all
kinds of different things you can forget
even the quantum aspect of quantum
computing and you can just sort of call
it physical computing
and
then you're asking the question well
what about these these substrates for
computing now most of what's done there
is thinking about things where the sort
of the structure of the computation
is the same as it is for a sort of a big
computer so to speak
um the uh or or a standard digital
electronic computer
and i think the um
um
uh the thing that um
uh
is yet a different idea
is
let's instead of
when we sort of have this free running
computation in a natural system that's
different from one of these computations
where we wrote the program ourselves
now we can actually go and this is kind
of the idea of this science that i'm now
calling ruliology um of just exploring
arbitrary sets of rules and seeing what
they do then you're kind of jumping to
somewhere that is uh out in the sort of
wilds of the computational universe and
being able to run sort of arbitrary
computations and the big question then
is how do those computations relate to
what we humans want to do
and what happens is it's very much like
kind of mining physical materials you
suddenly discover oh there's this
amazing kind of computation out there in
the computational universe and now i
realize what i can do with it you know i
might have discovered a fantastic
molybdenum mine or something in my
backyard or a samarium mine in my
backyard and if you don't know anything
to do with samarium then it's fine you
have that that mine and it's got
something in it but you doesn't seem
very significant but as soon as you
realize oh sumerian we're going to be
able to use that for this kind of magnet
or something like this and i know what
the purpose is to which i can apply that
are then it becomes very interesting and
the same is true with sort of
computations mined really logically from
the computational universe
let's see
uh
gosh
um
well there's a question here which i
think the answer is rather simple from
aaron
who asks why do cars get much hotter
than outside air temperature commenting
that that their car
its internal temperature was 130 degrees
fahrenheit while outside it was only 100
degrees fahrenheit i think the answer is
it's just like a greenhouse
that
uh
heat
is
there are
there are
several different ways that heat can be
transferred
what is heat heat is just the energy of
molecules bouncing around in the
material you're dealing with whether
it's air
or whether it's metal or whatever it is
heat is the energy of all those
molecules bouncing around randomly
inside the material
well
uh actually
there's
the heat is uh so how do you transfer
energy to something well one way you can
transfer energy is photons light from
the sun
uh taking energy that comes from the sun
and when that photon is absorbed it will
increase the energy of whatever absorbs
it whatever atom or molecule absorbs it
and so when you put something out in the
sun it gets hot because there are
photons carrying energy from the sun
and they uh excite the atoms or
molecules in the material which then run
around with with larger energy and
that's what makes the thing hotter now
what happens
in uh
sort of a confusing thing
which is that um
uh
glass for example
is a good transmitter a visible light
it's transparent that's what we use it
for to look through
but
what happens is light from the sun goes
through the glass
it uh it it takes its energy as it goes
through the glass it's it's the photon
that is going through the glass is
carrying a certain amount of energy then
the photon lands on you know your car
seat or whatever else
and it's absorbed by the molecules in in
your car seat
and
then what happens is
that causes the energy
of those molecules to increase so they
increase
their temperature
but then
they
whenever there's molecules running
around
at high speed and being accelerated and
colliding with other molecules and so on
that process
will produce photons
but it produces photons that are
infrared photons um if if you make the
um uh the molecules hot enough
that their kinetic energy is their
energy is high enough then the thing
will start to glow red hot white hot
blue hot whatever else
um but at lower temperatures below
where things are a white hot or whatever
that might be a few thousand degrees
centigrade would be white hot below
those temperatures
it will it will sort of glow producing
infrared light but at a much lower uh at
an infrared light that you can't see
that is much lower frequency light
um and so your you know the photon is
coming from the sun goes through your
your glass window
hits the car seat
produces a higher energy there but
what you might think would happen if if
the car seat was kind of out in the open
air is that you would you would kind of
know if the if if you had a mirror for
example there you would be the the light
would come in it would bounce off the
mirror and whatever energy was was being
brought in by the light would be would
go back out because that energy would be
carried by the photon that was was uh
reflected from the mirror but that's not
what happened happens in a typical
material instead what's happening is the
material is slightly heated up but there
are no sort of photons like the ones
that came in that go out again instead
there are sort of much degraded photons
that correspond to much lower
temperatures much lower energies and
those photons
they have the following thing happen
those photons don't get back out
those photons get stuck because glass is
not transparent to photons of that
frequency it's transparent to visible
light it's not transparent to uh
infrared light to things in the that are
sort of just the things that are that
are that we can't see in the visible
light range um but that are nevertheless
other photons that that carry energy
so
the other thing is the other way that
that um heat could be uh
uh sort of things could come to
equilibrium things i i should explain
one important feature of heat
is that normally if you have a whole
bunch of things
and
pieces of metal pieces of whatever
they're all connected to each other and
they will heat one of them up
the the in the usual situation
those things will come to equilibrium
all at the same temperature
they'll what will happen is that
the uh the molecules atoms whatever in
one material they'll be bouncing around
at a certain with a certain energy and
they will be at the at the interface
from one material to another they'll be
those molecules will be kicking other
um
uh you know the molecules on the other
side of the interface that will heat up
the next thing and so on and eventually
things will come to equilibrium all at
the same temperature
the very idea that there is a notion of
temperature
that that there is a way in which you
can characterize sort of the energy
associated with i don't know a bar of
metal or something as just in terms of a
temperature and you don't have to say oh
this is the energy of the mole of the
atoms in this part of the bar of metal
this is the energy in this part oh
there's this very detailed thing that
happens there's the molecules are all
marching in this direction in this part
they're all marching in that direction
in that part no they all get mixed up
and if you looked at them sort of under
a powerful enough microscope you'd see
that they were kind of bouncing around
randomly and they all bounce around
randomly with the same energy that's
kind of associated with the zeroth law
of thermodynamics
um this idea that you sort of come to
equilibrium like that
okay so
in order to come to equilibrium there
has to be a way to transfer energy
uh around the system to sort of
um and they're usually you can do it by
conduction you can do it by
molecules in a solid material for
example
actually uh sort of hitting other
molecules in that material and
conducting the heat from one place to
another um you can do it from radiation
that is photons being produced that will
transfer energy from one place to
another you can do it from convection
convection is something that happens in
in gases primarily where you have uh
let's say you have your bar of metal and
you have some air that gets right next
to the bar of metal well then conduction
will transfer heat from the bar of metal
to the air but then convection then that
that that piece of air can just move
away so hot air rises so it will tend to
be be uh you know what once it's heated
up it will tend to rise uh away from the
material and that's a way that also that
heat can be
sort of
taken away from a hot uh material
okay so usually
if you have some system
um that where lots of things are
connected together and so on they'll end
up all at the same temperature and so
you might think the air outside the car
would end up at the same temperature as
they are inside the reason that doesn't
happen
is that you no longer you can no longer
operate well convection doesn't work
because it's a closed car presumably
unless you leave the windows open
um
conduction well it works a bit
but the real driver is radiation
where there's heat coming in through the
windows with these photons of visible
light coming in and they are then
sort of
transferred converted to infrared
photons when they're absorbed and
re-transmitted they they don't have the
same frequency as the original light but
then
convection doesn't work and nor does
radiation you you can't get that heat
out of the car again and so what's
happening is that the that the radiation
from the sun is increasing the
temperature inside and that heat from
the inside can't get out and can't
equilibrate with the outside and that's
why greenhouses heat up that's why cars
heat up uh when when uh um
uh when the sun is shining in the
in in into them
um
let's see
uh
let's see
oh boy there's a question here uh a um
biomedical question from alex why
haven't we discovered a cure for
boldness
you know i i am
as somebody who's um uh
um
who's definitely afflicted
um
the uh
uh
i occasionally
have i followed the literature on this
on the subject
i mean basically
there are hair cells
which are continuously producing uh a
normally continuously producing um kind
of
hair follicles which are continuously
producing sort of
human hair
and
if they die they don't produce hair
anymore
so you know
can you kind of bring those back to life
can you make perhaps other cells
suddenly decide that they're hair cells
maybe
there's a what is it called wnt i think
it's a particular gene
that is very much associated with the
uh switching on that gene i think is
what's associated with the production of
of
of pieces of hair
and so if you can switch on that gene in
another kind of cell well then by golly
you can have
hair start to get produced
one thing to explain a sort of more
basic biological point to explain
is
uh
we're all we all have dna in all of our
cells the few hundred trillion cells
that we have in our bodies um every cell
has a copy of that same uh dna
that
is the sort of program that defines us
those six billion uh base pairs those
six billion lumps of atoms all in that
big long strand that makes a piece of
dna and that defines
us
and
when our cells kind of uh
the way that our cells kind of work in
the nucleus of each cell is that dna
and there's this process that causes
different parts of the dna to be read
and turned into proteins proteins are
the main things that we're made of
proteins are chains of amino acids
and what happens is the the the program
on the dna
is specifying oh
uh you know this is a gene that might be
i don't know a thousand base pairs long
a million base pairs long it's this gene
that's made from this chain of amino
acids it's this protein that's made from
a gene
uh on the genome and it's it's like a
sequence of thousands or millions of
amino acids long
and those proteins they're what make us
up they're what make our muscles and our
blood cells and our and our skin cells
and our hair cells and all those kinds
of things the the the sort of the the
the material that builds up those cells
is mostly protein
and the different kinds of proteins
there are maybe 30 000 kinds of proteins
that are common in in
us humans maybe 40 000 maybe a bit more
um and but they're all just these chains
of amino acids and
what's happening is that depending on
which amino acids are in the chain for
example the shape of the final protein
will be quite different some are long
and stringy like the ones in muscles
some are kind of folded up and make a
little cage like the ones in in red
blood cells
some
have different characteristics
and
the what happens is depending on which
amino acids are in the protein the the
thing will have a different mechanical
characteristics and it will fold up in a
different way to make a different shape
and once it's a different shape it will
have different uh sort of ways that it
fits together with other proteins
different ways that it can fit together
with other kinds of things and different
different activities
and
one activity
is
to produce keratin for hair and so on
and to be a hair cell but the question
is all our cells have the exact same dna
program how do some of those cells end
up
turning into hair cells versus
skin cells versus i don't know kidney
cells versus whatever else
that
pathway of differentiation
we all start from just one cell which
starts dividing and eventually we end up
with hundreds of trillions of cells
and which
what kind of cell each of those cells
ends up being is an important question
what's become clear in the last by 20
years or so
is that there are lots of kinds of ways
in which the dna gets modified the
environment of the cell gets modified
it's it's not the
actual original sequence on the dna it's
additional atoms that kind of hang
around the dna that help determine which
proteins will actually be made from the
dna that's in a particular kind of cell
so in any given kind of cell i don't
know how many types of proteins maybe a
few thousand proteins
are what's made in a particular cell and
those the which which few thousand
proteins are made will differ from one
type of cell to another okay why is this
relevant to to boldness well because
if you've got a you know you've got skin
cells and the question is can you coax
one of those skin cells to actually
decide oh actually i've decided to
become a hair cell i'm going to sprout
a nice uh
you know a very fine
piece of hair
and so the main thing that one one
thinks about i think
is you know can one coax those cells to
become a different kind of cell
see one of the things that people didn't
know for a long time is people assumed
that cells that could turn into any kind
of cell so-called pluripotent stem cells
that the only way you would get stem
cells that could turn into any kind of
any kind of cell was to have cells from
from a fetus for example
that were really in the natural course
of events would turn into a whole bunch
of different kinds of cells people
assumed that you had to go back to cells
that were uh there in a in an embryo to
be able to have cells that would have
this stem cell feature of being able to
turn into all kinds of cells but it was
discovered what 20 years ago now that
actually it's possible to go from
something like a skin cell and have it
revert it's still got the same dna that
any other cell has but it's got all
kinds of extra little pieces on that dna
and things that sort of tell it i'm you
know you're a skin cell but actually you
can get rid of those things and you can
have that skin cell revert to being a
stem cell and so when people talk about
stem cell therapies and so on in modern
times what they have in mind is to take
things that might be just skin cells and
go and revert them to go back to stem
cells and then if you're going to make a
therapy where you say well i'm going to
produce some some
kind of replacement
heart tissue heart muscle cells or
something or replacement cells of
another kind replacement pancreatic beta
cells to make insulin or whatever else
it is
what you then want to do
is to go back to the stem cell and then
say okay now go forwards
and differentiate
uh not into you're now a stem cell so
now turn into the type of cell that you
want to have it turn into and sometimes
like i think many kinds of cells are
like a dozen steps away from the
original stem cell so you have to
differentiate into this kind of cell
then this kind of cell and this kind of
cell and eventually get to the cell that
you're looking for and the surprising
thing that i didn't think was going to
work actually that people have been able
to do is to actually get cells to go
through all those different steps of
differentiation to wind up being a cell
that is of the kind that you were
looking for so i think that's one of the
main approaches to you know you know get
some hair cells back okay the original
ones died off but we can get new hair
cells that are um that come by by sort
of going back perhaps to the stem cell
stage or or somehow otherwise kind of
redifferentiating the cell to turn into
a different kind of cell so so for
example if you want to produce cells
that are um
uh
it's the same type of story in other
places you can either go all the way
back to stem cells or you can have a
cell that was really i don't know a
liver cell or something and have it sort
of redifferentiate itself to become
something like a pancreatic beta cell or
some such other thing like that so
that's kind of i think the idea and uh
that's kind of what you have to do is is
um uh now i suppose there are other
things you could do you could say if you
sort of say okay you know uh hair cell
you know you you thought you were dying
off but actually we're going to keep you
alive in some way or actually we're
going to make another hair cell um that
is uh being diff being uh
sort of from from that
uh sort of
breaking off another a copy of that hair
cell those might be other approaches but
but the thing i've just described i
think is the is the most plausible sort
of uh direction and it's kind of a uh
it's kind of a high wire act of of
complicated um uh sort of manipulation
of of of how cells differentiate and and
of course one of the issues when when
you're dealing with sort of
redifferentiating cells
is
uh you know tumors
are the results in some sense of kind of
a
a they are sort of yet a different kind
of cell that is being produced from your
intrinsic uh types of cells but they're
a type of cell that has the bad feature
that for example they don't stop growing
they just keep on replicating and you
keep on getting more and more and more
of those kinds of cells and eventually
that takes over and it's it's it's bad
for the rest of you so to speak and so
you have to be careful when you start
messing around with how to sort of
control the differentiation of cells
that you don't wind up by accident
making a tumor cell that just keeps
replicating um with it without stopping
the um
okay somebody is commenting paul is
commenting compared to other great apes
we've lost most of our body hair so i
wonder if boldness is not just a further
evolutionary crash progression
of uh uh and that might be true i mean
it's it's kind of like maybe maybe
those of us who's whose hair falls out
are the more evolved of um this
particular type of ape you know i i do
think that um
uh
in
you know one looks for
sometimes
it's always a trade-off when you think
about biology did something happen
um because of the mechanism of the
biological system or did something
happen because evolution carefully
controlled the biological system to have
that happen
you know do we do we end up
with an appendix in our in our guts
because
um it just happened that way because
it was that way in earlier times in
evolutionary history and we just didn't
get around in in sort of biological
evolution didn't get around to erasing
that irrelevant thing
or is it that way because actually we
are fito organisms when we have that
because you know something it affects
our microbiome in our gut or something
in some way that's positive at least if
we have certain sources of food or
whatever else
it's it's often very hard to tease apart
what happens by virtue of mechanism
versus what happens by virtue of of sort
of a control by a biological evolution
and sort of after the fact you can go
back and say well that happened because
and sometimes it happened because of
mechanism but then somehow the organism
realized oh
you know uh the fact is because i've got
my fingers arranged in this way
so i can peel some new kind of fruit in
some different way and then you're
eating that kind of fruit and then that
turns out to be a big win and so on but
it wasn't
that uh in a sense the um
uh
in a sense that was a side effect of
perhaps the you know evolution
controls things by virtue of the fact
that
you know you have some number of
offspring let's say let's say that uh
purple hair is something that's a really
good way
to
uh
i don't know
um
not get eaten by predators
and so
you know some particular
uh parents
have some you know purple haired
offspring and some green haired
offspring
and
the uh it is a random thing that they
might have you know uh
some fraction of um
uh
um
uh
the um
uh some fraction of of um
uh just by by virtue of kind of the
random
um
uh
way in which
the genomes of the offspring are
determined from the genomes of the
parents in the case of organisms like us
with sexual reproduction there are sort
of two two genomes that go in and they
get uh mixed together there is a long on
on every chromosome there are usually
about five or six different regions and
you'll get you know one region will be
from the mother one region will be from
the father and there'll be these
crossovers where you're kind of uh where
when when replication happens um when
the original replication happens
um
uh the um
uh
the the
apart comes from the the you know the
father's genome apart comes from
mother's genome it's this mixture and
that means that that mixing up means
that
if some part of that genome
is giving the program for green hair
some part for purple hair you'll end up
with some number of offspring with green
hair some number of offspring with
purple hair let's say so then the way
that sort of evolution works is okay if
the um
uh if the green-haired offspring all are
big losers because
the giant birds come and
come and eat those offspring then those
offspring are sort of taken out of the
picture only the purple offspring
survive
and then
when those purple offspring have their
offspring
the the um they have they will have the
purple hair jeans for sure not the green
hair genes and so they'll then be more
purple haired offspring uh later on and
so that's kind of the process of
evolution by natural selection by the
you know the bird coming and eating the
green head offspring or whatever um
that's that's how that works
now in the case of humans
uh evolution has become quite strange
probably because you know what matters
is basically how many how many kids do
you have and then how many kids will
your kids have and that will determine
at least in the current uh stage of of
human evolution that will determine kind
of what traits went out
so for example if it turns out
that um uh you're
uh
you know in um uh it's it's better to
not
be hairy because then you
lose heat more through your head and
that's good if the if if the climate is
warmer or some such other thing
and there's a if there's really an
effect that you're more likely to
survive to the point of having kids or
you're going to you're more likely to
have kids if you don't have any hair on
your head
then then that then biological evolution
will lead it to be the case that there
are more humans with with uh you know
without hair on their heads
now you know
in human society has an effect on
biological evolution because it could be
the case that who knows you know maybe
the bald-headed uh guys you know get the
gals more and so they're more likely to
have kids
and you know the ones with the giant
hair
are less likely to to get the gals and
so they might just not have any kids and
so then that sort of social dynamic will
lead to a biological evolution so to
speak that the uh you know the the the
genes that correspond to having you know
the the big hair and so on will will be
uh will eventually die out
um but so you know human evolution is
now somewhat determined by social forces
as well as by
uh kind of um
as well as by sort of what might be seen
as more pure biological forces now the
same is undoubtedly true for all other
organisms i mean there are there are
endless organisms that have elaborate
mating rituals and mating displays and
so on and although we don't really know
quite what the uh what the fashion is in
peacocks and so on um one can imagine
that the same types of things that play
out in human social dynamics and and
sort of that's of its effect on human
evolution also plays out out in peacock
dynamics um and uh you know whether uh
and maybe there's a season for um you
know maybe there's a
a a few decades when when it's really
cool to be a super thin peacock and
maybe there are other times when it's
where it's really cool to be a really uh
rotund peacock and so on um and uh you
know maybe that plays out in other
organisms as well but i think um
in uh
this now you know it gets much funkier
with human evolution
if we start doing gene editing in humans
and if people start saying
um gosh you know it's really cool to
have green eyes
let me just change my genome or change
my children's genomes by editing the eye
color gene and just change it to be
green eyes and that's something that in
the last decade or so it's been it's
been known uh in principle how to do
that although actual therapies based on
that are just starting to be um uh to be
used um some for some eye diseases and
so on um where you actually can go in
and
you're you're delivering something that
actually goes in and edits the genome um
and uh uh and changes um
uh and and then changes the fundamental
program that your cells are running
so but if that becomes something that is
a thing that is routinely done
uh with with humans and by the way by
the time you've um uh sometimes you you
can change that that genome for cells
that are kind of late in the stage of of
replicating where they're not going to
they're not like stem cells or something
but you can also imagine making those
changes uh right at the beginning and
the original cells that that uh that it
to make a human
and then you can um uh and then you can
expect that those those changes will be
passed down to the offspring of that
human and so on and so you've actually
made a a permanent change to the the the
um uh the germ line of the the the
actual genes that get passed down there
have been proposals to do this for
things like you know mosquitoes to
prevent malaria and so on it's a little
bit of a uh you know be careful what
you're doing type situation to have uh
to actually make a change
in a in a population and particularly
when you uh set things up so that you
kind of drive the change into the
population so that more and more
mosquitoes will end up having these
modified genomes it's like you know
things could go horribly wrong if you
made a mistake there and it's often hard
to tell
as kind of a fundamental feature that
comes from the sort of computational
character of biology that it's hard to
tell
what a particular change will lead to in
the end you think oh i'm changing it for
this purpose but the problem is just
like software and programs and bug you
could have bugs in programs you thought
you were writing a program to do this
but the computer did exactly what you
told it to do except there was something
you did not foresee and that caused it
to do something you you didn't want that
you would call a bug
um
the uh
uh
so
i think um
okay i have various comments here about
about how to describe
uh
the um
mating of humans i'm i'm i'm uh
um
i'm not sure i have much to comment on
that
um
the uh
it's always a question to what extent
we humans differ from sort of other
species in what we do
and uh you know is the mating display of
the humans really any different from the
mating display of the peacocks and so on
but you know what what seems to
differentiate our species from others
is uh you know that the kind of
what seems to differentiate is us is our
ability to pass on things other than
genetic
uh other other than genetically in other
words the fact that we have language
that allows us to describe things
abstractly that allows us to take things
we learnt
and pass them on to the next generation
so to speak and to do so
with this sort of abstract way of of
passing on thoughts that's something
that doesn't really seem to exist
elsewhere in uh um in in living systems
or at least we we don't recognize it
certainly there are there are things
where
there's i mean there's a there's a small
amount
that where you know it's like
uh okay you're a bird you should learn
to fly or okay you're a you're whatever
you should learn to hunt you know uh
it's kind of like watch what the parent
does and emulate it and you learn from
that but this concept that we humans
have of taking kind of abstracted ideas
uh sort of pure thoughts and being able
to communicate them to
later generations that seems to be
pretty that seems to be pretty unique to
us humans from what we can tell
and sort of the key invention that has
made that possible is human language
because you know the way to think about
it is in a brain there are thoughts
going on and those are associated with
little electrical impulses in our nerve
cells and all that kind of thing
but everybody's brain works slightly
differently and so the actual pattern of
electrical impulses it wouldn't be very
useful to take the pattern of electrical
impulses in my brain and kind of
transfer it wholesale to another brain
you know if what you're doing is showing
a physical motion you know what do you
need to do to swim what do you need to
do to to fly or whatever those physical
motions you know the the parent bird and
the child bird
uh will flap their wings in the same
kind of motion in order to fly they may
have slightly different you know
feathers and and their wings but
basically the you know you can you you
you know um i don't know what is it
monkey see monkey do whatever you can
you can explicitly see what you're
supposed to do because it's a big
physical motion but when it comes to
thinking
even if we had some kind of visual
display of kind of the patterns of
electrical activity in our brains it
wouldn't do
the other
uh person much good to see that stuff
because their brain is different
thinking is this very detailed thing you
couldn't just sort of transplant the the
pattern of neural activity from one
brain to another so we have to have some
sort of more abstracted description of
things that is transparent transportable
from one brain to another and that's
kind of where i think
the the notion of language and the idea
of sort of robust concepts and things
like words come in because you know we
say the word
cat
and
that corresponds to some particular
neural pattern in my brain it'll be
different in everybody else's brain but
yet
the notion of cat is something which we
can abstractly communicate from one
brain to another even though the details
of where the neurons are firing is
different and i think that's sort of the
key idea that has led our species to be
able to do the things it can do is that
we have this kind of layer of
abstraction that's captured in language
captured in things like words and so on
that allows us to transfer knowledge
from one detailed knowledge from one
organism to another from one generation
to the next and so on um and that's
that's sort of a crucial thing that that
has happened there
well let's see
uh
[Music]
oh my
lots of kinds of questions here
uh
let's see
um
rbs is asking about
um things in nature operating according
to rules
and why
different flowers have different shapes
and colors and so on
um
okay so
biological organisms you know one of the
big things they do is grow
and
different kinds of organisms have
different sort of big ideas about how to
grow so for example plants
they have a cell and they make new cells
but the walls of plant cells are rigid
they have
cellulose in them and uh that means that
you if if you want to grow as a plant
you have to just sort of add things on
you grow the big trunk up um higher up
for a tree you don't sort of just add in
more tree cells
into the trunk you're just always always
growing upwards so to speak for for us
animals we're more squidgy and we can
grow internal we can have cells inside
us where there are more of those cells
and we kind of you know
that thing just sort of pushes other
cells out of the way
so there's a
uh
this question of sort of
what rules are used for which plants to
make the shapes they make and so on
there are some sort of bigger
general rules like plants tend to use
branching and so on to make their
structures but the question of which
branching you use
well that becomes a more detailed
question the plant has sort of a big
idea but then there are more detailed
things controlled by the particular
dna of a particular plant
now one of the things that's confusing
about that is the way that geometry
works out you can have a plant plant
which is branching and it's branching
and it's making its branches make one
set of branches they make branches they
make branches and so on depending on the
detailed angles of those branches the
overall pattern that can be made can be
very different if the branches really
are sort of at big angles you'll end up
with something which is a very kind of
separated little fern-like thing if the
branches are much smaller angles things
will join up and you'll end up with
something which is a much more sort of
entire thing like a leaf or something
like that
so while it seems like that to us it
looks like oh the plant did something
really different
at some level it's actually very similar
it's just a very detailed change of the
angle that something branched out at
will lead to a really big change in the
actual structure of the growing plant
so i think what tends to happen with
lots of across lots of biological
organisms
is that a class of organisms will have
one basic idea like we're going to do
branching
and then different organisms different
species will have detailed differences
in how that works but those detailed
differences may visually to us look like
they're really different and moreover to
the actual operation of the plant or
animal or whatever it is it may have a
big effect because while it's a small
sort of effect to go from uh having your
skeleton be such that you routinely work
on walk on four legs that you gradually
change you know the shapes of bones and
so on and eventually oh we can walk on
two legs
and and then quite different things
become possible
i see a question here from aaron
about plant cells since we're talking
about plant cells and voronoi meshes
and animal cells and so on so okay
so
one question is
what shapes are the cells so if you look
at your look at your skin you will see
you know you can see the individual
cells on your skin
and uh they are you know that they're
sort of they're different shapes they're
often and skin cells they're often kind
of a like a parallelogram type shape and
so on they're different shapes if you
were to look at the cells in the back of
your eye you would see kind of a
hexagonal array of cells i think
um and and different kinds of things but
these cells they end up being different
shapes you have a whole bunch of cells
they're all sort of smooshed together
what shape do they make
well
that's that's a good question
and um
uh there are if you just imagine
a bunch of of cells that are just sort
of uh smooshed together you can imagine
taking some clay or something like that
just making sort of clay balls and
taking all these clay balls and just
smooshing them all together and uh what
kind of shape they're pushing them so
they're not they're no longer spheres
anymore they distorted a bit and you
kind of crush them so that they're all
fitting together what shape do they make
under those circumstances well actually
people didn't know that until in the
1940s 1950s people did experiments the
rather obvious experiment i just said
they smooshed together a bunch of clay
things they took it apart they saw they
answered questions like um
uh
how many
uh how if you have one of those clay
balls how many other clay balls were
kind of right around it um you know
touching it
so a thing to know
is that when you have when you okay if
you have circles and just in a plane and
you smoosh the circles together they'll
form always the same pattern a hexagonal
pattern around every circle there'd be
exactly six other circles they're all
touching it those six circles are all
touching six circles you get this
hexagonal pattern it's kind of like a
like a beehive um etc that's a typical
form that two-dimensional uh things
smoosh together make and so for example
when you have in plants there are places
where there are sort of cells that are
that are fibrous cells and they're
smooshed together and it's kind of like
it's like a planar thing like that and
they'll tend to make these hexagonal
patterns
um when you look at the
three-dimensional case where you've got
these balls being smushed together well
let's talk about spheres to begin with
if you take spheres
the um
uh
the closest packing of spheres is the
one that people tend to use to stack up
fruit in grocery stores the so-called
kepler packing
and every
how many is it
i think it's 20. every i think every
sphere
has 20 other spheres that touch it i
think that's right
um and that's the uh for a long time it
wasn't known whether that was the
closest packing whether that was the
packing of spheres that would would
minimize the amount of empty space
between that spheres those spheres are a
chap i know named tom hales
proved um in the uh
oh what is it now 15 years ago 20 years
ago now proved that mathematically that
that really is the closest packing that
had been sort of an open question since
the 1600s when kepler first started
really talking seriously about this was
it really the closest packing we know
that in two dimensions the hexagonal
packing is the closest packing three
dimensions what is the closest packing
there's a very difficult proof actually
done with our
mathematica software system
and then
kind of people didn't really believe the
proof because it was such a long and
complicated proof hundreds of pages long
and tom hales the person who'd done it
eventually said look you don't have to
believe me i'm going to make the proof
completely computational i'm going to
make it so that every step can be
immediately verified by a computer there
are no words involved it's all
computational language that took them a
decade sadly i'm not sure how many
people really cared about that it's like
well okay now it's completely nailed
there's no question about it this proof
is right but people kind of believed it
anyway although they said oh no no no
you really have to try and uh you know
give evidence for it and um uh that the
what they ask for is not necessarily
what they really want but any case so
it's known that that packing the capital
packing is the closest packing of
spheres
of equal size spheres
if you say well what happens if the
spheres are unequal size for example
still not knowing what the closest
packing is it's not even known for the
two-dimensional case where you have
unequal-sized circles you know quarters
and dimes or something what's the
closest packing it isn't known it's not
knowing even whether that's a regular
packing that looks like kind of a
crystal where every where around every
uh coin is the same configuration of
coins it could be sort of a random
packing that is the closest packing it's
not known
now by the way if you take spheres
and you just sort of throw them in a
ball pit and you say uh you know how
close can you pack them they will
typically not pack in the closest
packing however hard you smoosh them you
won't manage to get them to the closest
packing in two dimensions for circles
that does work but in three dimensions
it doesn't work you end up with these
situations where things are jammed and
you can't get there from here and you
have to kind of shake the balls
and that's what happens when you're kind
of trying to take some coffee or
something and you're trying to uh grind
push those coffee beans down you shake
it a bit and that causes the places
where the coffee beans are coffee
grains are
are jammed to they kind of cruises them
to kind of jiggle around and then they
can get closer to the closest possible
theoretical packing
okay so that's that's what happens with
with
sort of rigid balls
is you get there's a closest packing
which you don't achieve except by
carefully putting things that way or
sometimes by jiggling it around enough
but what happens with these kind of
clay balls or something like this that
are that are still flexible
well what happens is that the closest
the thing you get are tetracydecahedra
um uh tetracydecahedron is a is a 14
faced
um
uh
solid
well okay that's a very weird thing
because
the uh the sort of the most famous
polyhedra the platonic solids
uh the you know it goes tetrahedron cube
octahedron dodecahedron icosahedron
there are only five of those platonic
solids those are solids where every face
is identical so in a cube there are six
identical uh square faces on a
tetrahedron there are four identical
equilateral triangle faces on a
dodecahedron
there are
12 pentagonal faces and so on um
those are the only solids which you can
get
if all the faces are exactly the same
if you
and they're also convex they don't have
any any indentations in them if you uh
keep going and you say well actually i'm
going to allow different faces i'm going
to allow two kinds of faces or i'm going
to allow indentations and so on there
are many more polyhedra in fact you can
you can invent a polyhedron where you're
just putting a bunch of points down in
space and for example let's just imagine
you just have points in space and you
put shrink wrap on top of those points
in space
um that
will so so every every time there was an
interior point you wouldn't reach that
point because the shrink wrap just would
not would not go there but you shrink
wrap sort of the outer boundary that's
what's called the convex hull
of the set of points is that outer
boundary that you get by doing shrink
wrapping around them
um but you could get you could also try
to sort of approximate what's the way
that you would sort of have webbing on
top of those those points that you have
that would make you a different kind of
polyhedron uh with those points for
example as let's say corners of the
polyhedron
so in any case there are many polyhedra
you can make
but what happens when you smoosh clay
together like that
is you on average get 14 faced polyhedra
those are not regular polyhedra because
there are no regular 14 faced um
polyhedra that the there's the
dodecahedron with 12 faces there's the
icosahedron with 20 faces there's no 14
faced one um so those are irregular
polyhedra their faces are not all the
same but on average the faces that you
will get these 14 face things and i
think that there's a um
uh you you will get a distribution of
sizes of faces
um
uh
let's see there is a thing what is it
called the alboa of wear lore i think
is is one that describes
the um uh the sort of the distribution
of numbers of faces of numbers of of
faces in that particular case there's a
sort of a related thing if you are doing
okay let's talk about
the analog of shrink wrapping or
something let's say for points in the
plane
this gets us to this thing called the
voronoi diagram or vulnerable mesh
okay so imagine you have a bunch of
points in the plane
they let's imagine that those points are
i don't know
uh shopping centers okay
and you want to ask the question you've
got shopping centers all arranged in
different places and you want to ask the
question
uh
for any given person
which shopping center will they go to
if they go if they're closer to one
shopping center than another let's
assume that they'll always go to the
closest shopping center
and then what you want to do is draw a
map that shows around each shopping
center
where are the where do the people who
will go to that shopping center live
and
the that will be those people who are
closer to that shopping center than to
any other shopping center
and so what you can do is you can you
can kind of segment a map
by this is the region for this shopping
center this is the region for this
shopping center all those different
regions fit together they all have in
fact in the case i just defined they'll
all have straight edges because if you
imagine between two shopping centers
you're asking if you look let's say
there are only two shopping centers in
the world
what what will be the and assume that
the earth is flat so we don't have to
worry about spheres and all that kind of
thing you've got these two shopping
centers and you ask the question what
region is do people live in that's
closer to one shopping center than the
other well it's clear you can just make
a line the bisector of the of the line
between those two shopping centers will
be this line that just goes sort of
equally equally between the two shopping
centers it's a line that divides the
people who go to shopping center number
one versus shopping center number two
you generalize that when you put down
many shopping centers and there's this
whole network of lines that uh sort of
mark the distinction between one
shopping center and another and by the
way you can you can look at this in in
reality you can look at things like
commuters you know people living around
cities which city do they commute to
and you find that this kind of
arrangement of sort of the segregation
of things by uh sort of this this
mechanism is is quite prevalent in in
real life these things are usually
called voronoi diagrams of voronoi
meshes
this thing this sort of this arrangement
of lines that defines these regions
closer to one point than to other points
um and people there is a um
there are all sorts of strange things in
the in the um sort of theory of
geography there's uh one it's called the
um what is it called it's called the law
of retail gravitation i think which is
basically says that people will tend to
go to the more or less that people will
tend to go to the closest shopping
center it's a little bit more to it and
for a while people were really pushing
the idea that there was sort of an
inverse square law of attraction to
things like shopping centers which i
think was a bit confused because they
were sort of imagining that physics had
a universal result there which isn't it
isn't true at all i mean that the
results in physics has to do
specifically with gravity specifically
in three dimensions and so on so maybe
the space shopping centers where things
are arranged in three dimensions you'd
be it might be more relevant but uh not
not so much for for the two-dimensional
case but any case this so that's the
idea of a voronoi diagram you can do the
same thing in three dimensions you have
all these points
laid out in three-dimensional space and
you say what's the region that's closer
to one point than any of the others and
it will make a polyhedron it will make
an irregular polyhedron and so
that uh that kind of thing is what you
would potentially get
by having by sort of smooshing together
these balls of clay i don't think you
quite get that because what happens is
if the balls of clay are of roughly
equal volume that will tend to keep
those points far away so if you put down
points at random then you will get this
and you say what's closer to one point
than the other then you'll get this
voronoi mesh but if what you have is
physical balls of clay then each ball of
clay will tend to be sort of a roughly
equal distance away from another ball of
clay because that's just the same amount
of clay in each ball
but i think that the um uh what you end
up getting is instead of every
everything having exactly like 14 faces
or whatever there's a distribution of
face of numbers of faces
and um that is what gives you
uh
and that that's that sort of
characteristic of um what you get in
that situation it turns out to be a
pretty good model of the way that cells
in biological tissue arrange themselves
now there are a bunch of similar kinds
of things
uh in the two-dimensional case uh soap
films
are or
soap froths
um
are another kind of thing if you put a
bunch of soap in a sink or something and
you see all the bubbles there and you'll
see these bubbles and the bubbles each
bubble will have a certain number of
it'll it'll be uh arranged with a
certain they'll tend to be roughly
equal-sized bubbles
um because that's because of the way
surface tension works
and these bubbles will tend to arrange
themselves to eventually be roughly a
hexagonal array of bubbles
um
there is a a um
a a a
rule that tells you um the average
number the distribution of numbers of
faces of those bubbles so you could have
them all be perfectly hexagonal so it's
like kind of like a beehive um type
uh type setup honeycomb rather i should
say type setup uh of hexagons or you
could um uh but but sort of the
naturally occurring um soap froth
will have uh not quite arranged itself
in that honeycomb type fashion and if
you start looking at the distribution
the numbers of of sides some of them
will have will be i have five sides
someone will have seven sides eight
sides therefore there's a definite
distribution of numbers of sides um i
think that i think john von neumann was
involved in figuring out
that that um uh that at least
observation uh in his case from from
metal grains uh grains and a metal uh
that have been uh that had come from the
cooling of liquid metal
so
in any case the um
uh actually it's interesting that that
rule
okay so so that rule is what comes out
the number of sides that you get in the
soap film if you look at a soap film
what happens is there will be bubbles
there will be two neighboring bubbles
and they'll suddenly the the the line
between them will suddenly disappear and
they'll merge and then the other other
bubbles will sort of push on those
bubbles and make them closer to
to the sort of the average size and it
turns out there are particular sort of
moves that you can identify if you look
at the borders between bubbles there are
particular things that that happen like
there's a there's one where you have
sort of the two goes to one goes to two
configuration that turns into a two at
the v in a wedge with a line between
them one of those transforms to the
other you can think about these like
transformations on graphs
if you imagine just a pure network if
you imagine the
network of the borders between bubbles
you can draw that network and you can
imagine transformations on that network
that are associated with kind of the uh
the the coarsening of that
that foam uh formed from all of those
soap bubbles and so on
um so in any case the the results of
sort of
randomly applying those coarsening
transformations
is what gives you that distribution of
numbers of sides one thing that's
actually a bit surprising is it seems
like a rather elementary mathematical
kind of construct of you know you're
just taking this this graph and you're
coursing it and so on um i have never
found a simple derivation of the results
about this um the only derivation i know
goes all the way through conformal field
theory and feminine diagrams and so on
and loops back to talking about networks
that you get either abstractly or in or
in soap uh
soap foams and so on um it's a bit of a
surprising thing you know that you have
to kind of go out to really advanced
math and come back again to get that
result
but any case that that same result that
same kind of result
applies to the three-dimensional case
and sort of smooshing together things
like biological cells
now you know another thing that might be
mentioned there is that process of kind
of smooshing things cells together it's
a little bit like what happens in
liquids
so you know when you have a solid that
forms a crystal all the atoms are
arranged in some very regular way and
it's pretty typical to get a hexagonal
close-packed crystal for example where
you have um the atoms arranged in a
hexagonal array you can get cubic
crystals like like uh table salts and so
on you can get um different uh there are
26 kinds of crystal structures that you
can get where you arranging these these
atoms and collections of atoms in this
regular array but solid crystals the
atoms tend to be arranged in these
regular arrays in gases the atoms are
just bouncing around randomly in liquids
it's more like the the balls of clay
smooshed together you've got all these
molecules and let's say water or
something and they're all kind of
smooshed together and colliding all the
time and it's a little bit more like
what you have in the case of the the
balls of clay and so you can ask the
question well for example what's the
what's the typical
kind of configuration of things like if
you imagine around every molecule how
many molecules sort of touch it what's
imagine a polyhedron that you say this
is my territory as as one molecule where
are the nearest molecules to that
territory
well one of the weird things that
happens in in crystals
in liquids rather is that you quite
often get um uh
um
you you get kind of icosahedral
uh sort of effective icosahedral
structures okay why is that weird
if you
imagine
taking cubes for example you know that
you can just stack up cubic bricks and
you can make any sized object from them
if you take
um let's say certain kinds of um well
you take hexa hexagonal prisms you can
do the same thing you just you just uh
sort of put the prisms together in a in
a pavement and then stack those up
that's kind of the structure of graphite
for example is carbon atoms arranged
that way
um and there are other shapes there are
a limited number of shapes there's a um
oh my gosh uh cuboctahedron is another
shape which is an octahedron with with
its um with its points sort of chopped
off that's another uh type of solid that
fills space you can just pack them all
identical solids like that together to
fill space and those are the
configurations it's those things and
those kinds of packings that lead to the
structure of crystals but in a liquid
you don't have that kind of regular
packing you have all these things kind
of jiggling around and getting smooshed
together a little bit like those clay
balls i was talking about so the
question is what shapes do you get and
the weird observation is that you
sometimes get kind of approximate
icosahedral shapes if you take
icosahedra 20 faced
polyhedra with with
with triangular faces you take a bunch
of of icosahedra they don't fill space
you can't you can't pack them together
they've got holes between them if you
try and pack together regular regular
icosahedra but if you're just doing this
jiggling around and sort of randomly
having molecules kind of just be nearby
for a little while and then then go away
as they do in a liquid then you can get
something which has an approximate
icosahedral structure and that seems to
be what happens in some to some extent
at least in liquids different liquids
work differently water is an incredibly
complicated case water ends up with
these clusters of molecules it's not
very well understood yet um these kind
of clusters of molecules that are that
are very organized within the water it's
like miniature little pieces of of of
pseudo solid that exists at a very very
microscopic level in water that
gradually get that progressively get
broken up and reformed and so on but uh
what has a particularly complicated
structure is a liquid but that's kind of
the idea is that there's this there's
this kind of uh not
uh you know imprecise kind of smooshing
together of
of different parts that lead to certain
forms of of uh geometrical structure
that are different from what can be
achieved if you really want to
fill up space and so on
let's see
uh
there's a question here from universe
do you believe that a concrete
description of evolution is waiting to
be fleshed out within the
multi-computational paradigm
um
and if so
does its basic rule relate to expansion
of hypergraphs and so on so what's being
referred to there is is our
models that have arisen from trying to
understand fundamental physics
and um
the uh let me not go into a big
description of that here but suffice it
to say one of the key ideas is this
notion of multi-computation
there's
the the idea oh there's a definite rule
you can follow and you go from one
situation to the next to the next and to
the next but imagine you have a game
like tic-tac-toe for example at every
step there are many possible things that
could be done next
you can make kind of a graph of all
those possible histories for tic-tac-toe
sometimes you'll have two at a
particular board state you'll have two
different things that can happen that's
a branch in the history sometimes you'll
have uh two different board states where
you fill the board in and they end up
looking the same even though they came
from two different states that's a merge
you get this multi-way graph that
describes sort of the set of all
possible histories of how a tic-tac-toe
game could be played that's kind of a
multi-computational phenomenon where you
have all these different possible paths
of computation that are entangled with
each other
so a question is what about biological
life
what about evolution
well it's pretty common to draw this
thing that's usually called the tree of
life
that imagines that you start from the
very first organism
and it gradually evolves into you know a
fish
and a lizard and so on and you've got
this big branching of all these
different possible forms of life
starting with the very earliest form of
life presumably life only arose once on
earth who knows at least maybe only one
of these origins of life survived so you
end up with this with this sort of
branching tree
as different species get produced as as
what happens is you know in the i was
talking about the the green head the
purple head
creatures maybe uh what happens is that
the um after a while the green haired
creatures only mate with green haired
creatures and purple only with purple
and you get these sort of separate
species formed of the green ones and the
purple ones
um
so
that um and and sort of the way you
imagine life on earth kind of uh
emerging is this that you talk about
this kind of large-scale tree of life
where you're sort of branching off all
these different species um that get
produced
i'm more interested actually right now
in a more extreme genealogical tree of
life
i mean if you draw
your personal genealogy you know you
have two parents
there are four grandparents
there are you know grand grandparents
eventually maybe some of those
grandparents will be the same people um
so it isn't it isn't quite a a tree even
going backwards so to speak and you
might have some number of children they
have children you'll get kind of the
tree going forwards it isn't it isn't
perfectly a tree because you know when
you have distant enough cousins they
might be marrying each other and then
you'd get sort of a merge in the tree
and things like this but you can make
this big genealogical tree
for example for humans
and um uh you know the hundred billion
humans who've ever lived there is a
definite genealogical tree that connects
all those humans you know in iceland for
example i think the perf the complete
genealogical tree going back to a
thousand ad is known but in most parts
of the world it's not known although one
can piece together some approximations
to it but any case let's uh you imagine
this completely genealogical tree of all
the relations between all these
organisms all these humans in that case
but imagine let's scale that up
to to all organisms that have ever lived
on the earth
and you know there's some that have
asexual reproduction there's some you
know where there's just one parent
producing many many offspring there's
ones where there are two parents and so
on the the the like for for uh you know
sort of all the modern creatures um
but um
the uh
uh then
uh you can you can imagine this whole
sort of it's actually a graph
of relations genealogical graph of
relations in all organisms that have
ever lived i don't know how many there
are i was trying to estimate that
recently there's maybe a maybe a
trillion trillion trillion trillion
roughly organisms that have lived on the
earth since the origin of life three
billion years ago or so now
um and so
you've got all those relations
and one thing that you do is in that
graph
you can kind of identify regions of the
graph that correspond to different
species regions of the graph where there
really isn't much cross connectivity
because there isn't mating across
species that's kind of the the typical
operational definition of a species is
that it only mates within the species
and not to other species and so that
that has some
uh so what's happening is this giant
genealogical graph is broken into these
sort of blobs that correspond to all the
different species and if you look only
at those blobs you kind of zoom out and
look at those blobs then that gives you
the tree of life presumably but now the
question is well what does it really
look like down the level of its
genealogical graph
well one thing you realize is
species mating there are two
determinants of that one is well are
they the same species
the other is do they ever even meet each
other you know maybe one's living in
australia and one's living in siberia uh
you know and they're and they're uh you
know some type of small rodent or
something the one in siberia is not
going to meet the one in australia at
least not in that generation
and so there's sort of a spatial
component to the whole thing as well so
there's both in in terms of our physics
project we talk about spatial separation
of things
corresponding to what happens in
physical space we also talk about
branchial
separation in terms of the branches of
history of our universe
when we're thinking about that in terms
of fundamental physics it's all wound up
with quantum mechanics
but what we have here in the case of
evolution is kind of branchial
separation is genealogical separation
bronchial separation is how you know you
you might have a a 15th cousin
you know 15
10 times removed or something as you get
a sufficiently distant cousin that is
bronchial separation that's bronchial
distance is the number of cousin levels
that you're going and by the time you
know i'm sure that uh i don't know how
many cousin levels you have to go before
you reach uh non-human primates from us
i'm gonna guess
[Music]
let me see there are a hundred billion
humans that have lived and they've had
um
uh
let's see how many generations maybe
let's give us a couple hundred thousand
years
um we've got maybe ten thousand
generations of humans so i'm gonna guess
yeah i'm gonna guess by the time you're
at the ten thousandth cousin
uh it's an ape a non-human primate um
but uh uh
you know and so so you kind of have to
go distantly on this on this branchial
graph bronchial dimension of the graph
so i kind of have this suspicion that
thinking about
the dynamics of
uh
sort of branchial separation spatial
separation and time the actual the the
you know what what happens through time
is a new organism is born
and then eventually a new organism dies
and actually in most of nature the new
organism dies because it's eaten
and so then you have this kind of idea
there's an additional kind of network
which is the food web network where an
organism has you know
one one organism eaten by another
organisms which is eaten by another
organism you know on on land i think
it's like five trophic levels or
something typically of of one organism
eats another organism until you
eventually reach you know the apex
predator so to speak and then in the
oceans i think they're more like 20 30
levels where you know a little fish is a
you know bigger fish there's always a
bigger fish that can eat the smaller
fish so to speak but sort of the concept
would be that one can imagine sort of
the whole
genealogical tree of everything that's
ever lived and everything that's ever
eaten and a thing um and
that somehow the construction of that
that graph
will have certain invariant properties
just as the construction of the graph
that represents space-time has certain
invariant properties that lead us to
phenomena like gravity and so on so it
is my guess
that that
very large graph that corresponds to the
possible configurations of all the
organisms that ever lived will have
certain universal properties that we can
identify one of those properties might
be the very fact that species form there
may be other properties that we don't
yet know that are sort of global facts
about biological evolution that we can
deduce just like we can deduce global
facts about space-time from knowing what
uh you know down at the level of sort of
the atoms of space there's this big
network of connections between atoms of
space but if we kind of zoom out there
are big features like black holes like
gravity like different aspects of space
time and so on that we can see and maybe
there are similar things that are true
for kind of the the genealogical or
biological evolution
uh structure that can exist in in in
that case and i i kind of suspect
something like that is true and it needs
to be worked out and i haven't done it
yet and uh something maybe at our new
wolfram institute it may be one of the
topics that we'll look at is biological
evolution thought about in kind of this
multi-computational way
um
let's
see people asks if mammals have a common
ancestor how did they get divided into
carnivores and herbivores that is a good
question
well
you know remember there's something in
the middle like us we're omnivores we've
got both the pointy teeth and the
grinding teeth you know we eat both both
vegetables or some people choose to eat
only one or the other but but
most people eat both vegetables and uh
you know both plants and animals
so there's sort of a an in-between and
so my guess is
that there were uh precursor organisms
mammals even
that um had various tendencies towards
omnivorousness or like well i mostly eat
meat but gosh if i see that particular
kind of juicy fruit my teeth will allow
me to eat it
and um
i eat it and it works out well kind of
thing and then there's gradual sort of
evolution in that direction so i kind of
think it's not the case that you know uh
the the there's so kind of a a a
a gradual a gradualness that you can get
from carnivores to herbivores and and
the way you see that is literally in the
shapes of teeth the carnivores have
pointy teeth for cutting meat the
herbivores have have flattened teeth for
grinding vegetable material
um so that's my guess about how that
works um
let's see john here is asking what do
you think of the notion of chemical
interspecies communication
well you know
there's interspecies communication at
some level i mean you can see the
the
the dog wagging its tail
you can see the expressions on the face
of the dog you can hear the box of the
dog there is some level of interspecies
communication that works that way
in terms of a sort of finer grained
interspecies communication where you're
really uh you know transferring the the
great thoughts of one species
civilization to another uh we don't know
how that works if it works but certainly
pheromones uh molecules that
are kind of secreted by one organism
intended as sort of a a way to
communicate with other organisms
those are those might have more detail
than so for example a typical uh you
know that they're typically molecules
there are i think they're they're often
particular kinds of molecules don't
occur so often in other places like an
11 length 11 um
[Music]
long chain of carbon atoms with with
hydrogens connected to them is is a is a
type of pheromone um and uh used by
insects i think that particular one
and in a sense it's like different you
know forms of perfume or something
they you can have these different
molecules that are sort of representing
different kinds of things so some some
animal you know dog
uh
well i don't know maybe skunk in a more
extreme case but these different kinds
of animals will sort of mark out their
territory by laying down these molecules
these pheromone molecules
that sort of communicate to other
organisms now one thing that's true is
that you know the that organisms have a
certain molecular diversity so you know
one the smell of one organism is
different from the smell of another
organ that's why you can have you know a
dog you you kind of have it you know
smell something from you know that that
picked up the the scent of a person and
the dog can then go track that person
and so on um that happens because we all
have a slightly different um it is
something determined by our genetics
we have um
uh you know we have different we're
shedding different molecules that lead
us to to smell different so to speak um
and that's what uh and there's there's
great diversity in that um which is why
you can expect you know the dog to go
find the right person and so on um and
so that and that exists in in all kinds
of organisms um this idea that this sort
of diversity in in this in the smells of
different members of the species
and that is sort of something that can
be used to kind of mark out territory
and so on i i don't know the extent to
which um
there is control of the molecules that
are produced
um whether there are examples of that
um where you can kind of lay down you
know for example you could imagine you
know okay the extreme this is a is a
good science fiction insect or something
is um you know it it uh it writes its
great works in pheromones on the ground
so in other words it's uh you know it's
it's it's going around it's sort of
hanging out it's walking along it's it's
walking along it walks along one line
then the next then the next always
producing secreting some different
pheromone some different molecule of
some different scent and as it's doing
that maybe it's it's drawing its great
piece of artwork
in in smell space so to speak uh we
don't know whether that happens i i
certainly don't know of it but i don't
think we would know of it because we
don't have good ways of detecting these
things i mean we don't have good
uh you know artificial noses we have
good artificial eyes namely cameras um
and uh you know they which which do the
same kind of thing of detecting light
that our eyes do but when it comes to
noses
things that are detecting all these
different shapes of molecules that have
different smells we don't have good ways
to do that yet and it's still quite
unclear how it works i mean probably in
our noses we have different receptors
different molecules there that have
different sort of uh holes in them that
fit different shaped molecules so when
you smell
some particular kind of thing you smell
some particular kind of flower or
something like that
there will be molecules of there'll be
molecules in the gas that come out of
that flower and those molecules will be
fairly small molecules probably if
they're in gas phase um but they are
they will then kind of lodge themselves
into these molecules that are in your
nose
that
and those molecules in your nose
probably fit only molecules of a
particular shape and so what happens
when you smell a particular smell
is you've encoded in your brain oh there
are sort of detectors in this region of
my nose that are associated with the
green smell and others that are
associated with the purple smell now
obviously smells don't naturally have
colors but you can imagine
just like in the eye
there are three kinds of cone cells that
detect basically red green and blue and
in our brains we've wired up the red
cone cells to be the things that allow
us to sense red in light and so
similarly one imagines that we've wired
up
the uh the the nose cells so to speak
that are um that allow us to detect a
particular kind of smell we've wired
those up to the place in our olfactory
bulb in our brains
where um the um
uh
where we're kind of disentangling what
smells like what it's a complicated
story i mean the tongue for example with
taste buds has its own complicated thing
where they're these little sort of uh
cavities where little particles of food
get stuck there there are different
kinds of of cavities that that sense
different kinds of sweet and sour and so
on taste it's not well understood yet
how that all works it's not well
understood the extent to which it's sort
of a chemical reaction that's happening
in the taste bud versus the fact versus
the kind of the physical arrangement of
the molecules that are just sort of
fitting into to crevices in the in the
molecules in the taste bud and so on but
so you know we don't really have a great
way of doing what you know dogs do
pretty well of you know a dog if if if
there was the great artwork put by the
the science fiction insect on the ground
you know the the the painting painted
with pheromones you know a dog might
have a much easier time he'll just go
sniff sniff and it'll walk down the
lines of the painting and so on maybe
it'll lose interest because it doesn't
know what the heck it's it's smelling
but um uh you know it would have a much
better chance of of having a oh wow
that's a that's a really cool painting
so to speak than we would because we
just don't have our own sense of smell
is not good enough to be able to
distinguish things on that scale and so
on and we don't have automated ways yet
of having sort of good artificial noses
where we can detect those different
kinds of things for any particular kind
of molecule you know you have a co2
detector you have a carbon monoxide
detector you have
a detector of some particular kinds of
volatile
uh chemicals in the in the air and so on
for some very particular kinds of
molecules we can make good good
detectors where you can have get an
electronic signal from the presence of
that kind of
molecule and usually that's done with
electrochemistry usually it's done by
having some chemical reaction that is
has an electrical effect uh sort of a
very inverse version of a battery where
you're using electrochemistry to produce
electricity you're using chemistry to
basically well i suppose it's the same
thing really you're using some kind of
chemical process to produce an
electrical signal that allows you to
detect the presence of that kind of
molecule but we don't know kind of a
broad spectrum way to do that
uh you know we've we've had you could
imagine a uh
a camera which just has sort of one
pixel it's just is there light or is
there not light um but in fact we can
have these arrays of pixels millions of
them and red green and blue detecting
pixels and even hyperspectral cameras
where we detect different kinds of
frequencies of light and so on um
and uh it's um
uh so so that there's there's kind of a
whole
um uh that's something where we can do
it for vision we can do it in this very
broad spectrum way we don't yet have the
technology to do that for for for smell
for old faction um and uh when we do
maybe we'll discover that you know dogs
have been writing big messages to us all
along or or something like that i don't
know it's an interesting case where sort
of the the things that are out there in
the world could be a lot different than
we them we know
because just our senses have detected
only some aspects of the world
all right i should probably wrap up very
soon here
um oh boy there's uh
um
uh
the question from em here can we think
of some fungi species that could reach
some kind of intelligence in the future
like humans
well you see the thing about stuff like
that is
you know there are fungi that are these
very you know extended organisms that
stretch over over large regions and have
just a lot of lots of material in them
and you know maybe
there are
fungi
that have some very complicated
transport of material inside the fungus
maybe there's electrical activity maybe
it's almost like brain activity that's
happening in the fungus
and you know we could at a scientific
level we could say we can measure this
we can see something's happening but if
we say is that fungus thinking is that
fungus you know making great works of
fungus literature we don't have a clue
because
the
you know there isn't really an alignment
between kind of our way of thinking and
the fungus way of thinking it's it's
it's
and even for the things i was describing
about smell and and so on you know our
way of thinking about things very
different it's very visual you know we
for example we will you know write out
things in um
uh you know on pieces of paper or
whatever it's very different from from
something where
we do that for people to be able to see
them so it's very difficult to tell you
know whether there is a great
civilization in the fungi and we just
don't have any idea and at some level uh
you know i think there is it's just far
away
in terms of sort of the interpretation
of what's going on from what we're used
to as humans
ah
all right we should probably
wrap up here
um
oh there's one here that maybe is fairly
simple from pippo
are bubbles round because of gravity no
it's not because of gravity the the um
bubbles around
because of surface tension
they
um
okay first to math fact
if you
are going to
enclose the maximum area
with the minimum perimeter
the way to do that is make a circle
as soon as you have corners you're sort
of wasting
a fence
you're wasting a piece of fence by going
out to that corner if you want to uh you
know keep in the maximum area the best
way to do it is to have a circular fence
as soon as you you push out a corner
you're using more fence but not
including much more area
so
that that's the so another way to put it
is given a particular area if you want
to have the border of that area to be as
small as possible you're going to pull
it in until it's a circle
okay so same as two in three dimensions
that this the the best way to enclose a
volume is with a sphere
and so what happens in in bubbles is
that there
the the the soap
is is trying to enclose the maximum
volume with the minimum surface area of
soap
why does that happen it happens because
of this phenomenon called surface
tension and how does surface tension
work what's essentially happening is
that molecules in the surface
are pulling on each other
and
they
don't have anything to pull so if you if
you if you extended beyond that surface
there will be much more force pulling
the molecules into the surface than
pulling the molecules out of the surface
and so that will
make it be the case that
you end up sort of always trying to pull
the molecules together in the surface
and that leads to the surface tension
which leads to minimizing the area of
the surface
um in um uh
and that's why that's why soap bubbles
are more or less round now another thing
that's round is something like a star or
a planet
or
a drop of water that's falling um
the actually
these are different so okay the drop of
water it's a surface tension story same
same story as with and the reason that
happens is the molecules inside the drop
of water are always pulling on their
friendly molecules say come into the
interior of the water where we're
hanging together as a liquid so anything
at the surface if there was a tower that
developed on the surface it wouldn't
survive because all the molecules inside
the water will be tugging on that tower
to pull it into the interior of the
water and so it would it would end up
getting smoothed out and and a round um
uh
blob of water now you know it also has
to be said that
under gravity
that
gravity wins against surface tension if
you have a drop and that drop is um uh
and you put it on a surface it'll it'll
kind of smoosh out
um because gravity is pulling on it and
preventing it from being that that so
that spherical shape now there's another
phenomenon which is uh called wetting
w-h-e-t-t-i-n-g
um the uh which is uh the question of
when you have a solid surface and a
liquid drop just how much does the solid
surface cause the liquid drop to kind of
spread into the solid surface and it's
quite common when you have um uh some
kind of uh um
uh well there are many many materials
which have this feature that they tend
to keep drops from spreading into them
some materials are very absorptive some
solid materials very absorptive and the
drop will just quickly kind of
kind of decay and get spread out into
the solid material others you'll kind of
keep the drop
because the solid material will kind of
say we don't want pieces of liquid in
the solid so the drop is is maintained
in that form but the way that the reason
that things like stars and planets and
so on um the reason that they're
spherical is because of gravity because
what's happening there
is in the end it's the same effect that
it minimizes the surface area but it
happens for a somewhat different reason
it's it's not happening because the
surface is sort of pulling things in
it's happening because the whole volume
of the material is kind of acting on
every every
every part of the that there's mass
inside the thing and that mass is having
a gravitational effect that goes all the
way out to the edge of the of the object
and that gravitational effect is making
the is making things as close as
possible to the center um and the way to
make a a certain amount of material as
close as possible to the center with a
given amount of material is to make it a
sphere
because you're kind of having layers of
that sphere going out and every time you
add more stuff it's like well we want to
be a sphere we don't want to be a tower
that's stuck up but but the difference
between gravitational forces is they're
long-range forces where the center of
the star
the stuff at the center of the star is
exerting a gravitational force on what's
at the surface whereas in surface
tension it's a local thing on the
surface that that there is that there
are forces purely between things on the
surface of the object that are causing
it to have minimum area surface as
opposed to throughout the volume of the
thing
all right i think i should uh wrap up
here
so um
thanks very much i see lots of questions
that we'll save up for another time
well thank you for joining our hundredth
science and technology q a for kids and
others um i
remind people
uh
there is a way of submitting questions
for future
uh
future episodes i also remind people
that we now have a hundred as of today a
hundred recorded episodes
um
where i've talked about just a huge
range of different kinds of things thank
you for asking me about different kinds
of things all the time um and uh you'll
find um those things uh uh on the web as
podcasts and so on i do wonder you know
at some point uh sort of i will have
said everything i know in one episode or
another um maybe um and uh at least
everything i know about these kinds of
science and technology questions um but
uh i think we're still we've still got a
ways to go so i think that um uh and i
also learn new things every every every
day every week i learn new stuff
and uh you know i have to say what i
what i tend to do as i as i try and
answer things here is i i do um uh you
know i don't really have big flags for
whether i learned something yesterday or
50 years ago um and uh so
uh i i'm usually making a mixture of
things that um i've known for a long
time and things that i've learned only
quite recently
and um also i i try to give some
indication when things
are things that are very recent facts
that have only been discovered
scientifically recently versus things
that have been known for a long time but
there's a big mixture of those kinds of
things and the questions people ask here
there is a kind of a wonderful mixture
of things where it sort of should be
answerable by anybody with decent
science education and questions where
it's like gosh well actually i can
answer that because i recently talked to
the world expert in that area because
i've worked on that problem myself and i
kind of know what the absolute frontier
of that is it's kind of a thank you guys
for for giving me a wonderful mixture of
those different uh levels of sort of
scientific uh questioning
all right well i should wrap up here for
now and uh hope to see you um another
time episode 101 and beyond
bye for now